je
un coup
o o
e
en tout
même
oh
voilà c'est exactement le genre de petit
concert auquel vous pourriez assister si
vous étiez hospitalisés ou incarcérés
c'est exactement le genre de petites
formations qu'on peut exporter à
l'hôpital facilement donc de flûte et un
basson avec mes amis benoît loïc on a
déjà d'ailleurs joué dans cette
formation exactement la même dans
plusieurs endroits
donc si vous étiez dans ces lieux où
l'association papageno intervenait donc
l'association papageno regroupe des
musiciens professionnels et organise des
concerts de musique de chambre auprès
des publics dits empêché alors que sont
ces publics empêchés ce sont les gens
qui pour des raisons de santé
d'exclusion sociale momentanée ou plus
ou moins longue d'ailleurs ne peuvent se
rendre au concert et c'est donc le
concert qui vient à eux c'est un
principe très simple puisque les gens
peuvent pas bouger nous on est mobile
donc c'est nous qui allons aller vers
ces gens alors vous avez peut-être me
dire vous êtes en droit de penser mais
comment ces gens sont déjà empêché ils
sont dans la capacité de s'enfuir et
vous leur infliger une heure de musique
classique c'est quand même pas très
sympa alors évidemment l'idée c'est pas
d'infliger une contrainte supplémentaire
mais plutôt de d'ouvrir une fenêtre sur
l'extérieur peut-être sur la vraie vie
il vous fait d'offrir une bouffée
d'oxygène ou au mieux de partager eu une
heure d'émotions musicales et en fait ça
fonctionne très très bien donc c'est
vrai qu'on fait ça avec deux petits
arrières pensées donc la première serait
de dire pourquoi est ce que les
puissances politiques ne prendrait pas
le relais par exemple la mer deux
communes et ce qui se dira eh ben moi
qu'est ce que je fais dans ma commune
pour aller auprès des publics empêchés
comment je fais pour qu'ils aient plus
de culture de la musique classique
auprès des gens qui n'ont pas la
possibilité de l'écouter qu'est ce que
je pourrais faire et on a la naïveté de
penser que d'amorcer un tel programme ça
pourrait être pérennisée par la suite
bon en attendant l'association continue
d'aller dans les prisons les hôpitaux
les maisons de retraite et les écoles de
zep
par exemple ces fameuses zones
d'éducation prioritaires dans lesquels
on est parfois amené à faire un peu de
pédagogie
c'est à dire par exemple a expliqué que
non beethoven n'est pas un chien est en
tout cas pas que un chien voilà et la
deuxième petite idée qu'on a c'est aussi
de dire vous public peut-être que quand
vous serez en mesure de le faire venez
dans les lieux de concerts car on aider
les musiciens classiques après tout on
est des gens normaux on n'est pas des
dinosaures les lieux de concerts sont
ouverts à tous ils sont pas réservées ni
à une élite ni un public d'initiés
ici pas de belles choses et il faut il
faut y aller sans avoir peur par exemple
de ne pas savoir comment s'habiller
c'est vrai que nous on est en queue de
pie ix et en robe du soir mais vous
pouvez venir en blue jeans et si vous
savez pas quand applaudir et ben c'est
pas grave moi j'ai un petit truc pour
vous vous attendez que tout le monde
applaudit ces vous à plantes vous
applaudissez ensuite les ça marche très
bien
voilà donc l'association existe depuis
une quinzaine d'années à paris et à lyon
et elle se produit dans ces deux villes
et dans un rayon assez large autour de
ces deux villes
les musiciens qui la composent sont
issus des grandes formations
symphoniques ou lyrique de paris ou de
lyon
donc pour la plupart l'opéra national de
paris
et puis ici à lyon leur caisse nationale
de lyon et les musiciens sont
entièrement bénévoles
on a plus de 300 concerts à notre actif
et chaque fois qu'on joue dans ces
conditions danse dans ces lieux peu
différent pour nous eh bien on est on se
dit qu'on devrait le faire plus souvent
parce que c'est toujours des expériences
très enrichissantes
alors pourquoi papageno alors si vous
connaissez l'opéra de mozart la flûte
enchantée opéra que j'aime
particulièrement bien sûr parce qu'il
met en scène
mon instrument vous connaissez peut-être
le personnage de papageno qui est un
personnage secondaire mais très
important donc ce personnage se voit
confier un jeu de clochettes magique et
à chaque fois qu'il est dans une
situation inextricable qu'il est
désespéré il sort son jeu de choc de
clochettes ils jouent les clochettes et
tout s'arrange
on a de nombreuses références au côté
magique de la musique également dans
beaucoup d'autres oeuvres d'art est dans
la mythologie par exemple vous avez le
mythe d'orphée donc orphée quant à lui
s'est vu doter d'une lire par le dieu
apollon le dieu de la beauté qui lui a
donné cette lire qui lui permettait de
charmer les pierres les plantes
d'adoucir les âmes de faire pleurer les
hommes et de d'adoucir même les dieux
est renvoyé à l'ecc tout ça donc le côté
magique de la musique
en tout cas nous on le vit au quotidien
parce que quand on joue auprès de ces
publics empêchés
on se rend compte que bon c'est
peut-être pas magique mais en tout cas
il ya vraiment quelque chose qui se
passe c'est difficile à expliquer avec
des mots m'ont a l'impression quand même
d'amener quelque chose à ces publics
nous ça nous amène aussi beaucoup parce
que
déjà ça nous sort du concert de du
confort de la salle de concert parce
qu'on joue dans les couloirs on joue
dans des salles qui sont pas du tout
dédié à la musique et donc forcément il
faut s'adapter en plus l'activité du
lieu ne va pas s'arrêter pour nous donc
quand on joue à l'hôpital il ya les
chariots qui passe il ya les patients
les familles etc qui déambulent donc
pour nous ça déjà ça nous met un petit
peu en difficulté parfois instrumentale
en tout cas ça nous sort de notre
contexte habituel
et puis en général c'est vrai qu' on est
on est toujours heureux de
d'expérimenter ces nouvelles ses
nouvelles ces endroits alors par exemple
quand on joue dans les grandes salles de
concert
c'est vrai qu'on a pas beaucoup de
contacts avec le public
parfois même pas du tout parce que quand
on joue dans la fosse d'orchestre si on
est un orchestre d'opéra on joue en
fosse on voit pas du tout les gens on
sait qu'ils sont là parce que ils
applaudissent éventuellement aussi parce
qu'il tousse tousse beaucoup notamment à
lyon mais sinon on n'a pas dé change
vraiment donc c'est vraiment une belle
expérience pour nous que d'aller auprès
des patients on est dans un couloir
d'hôpital
on est quatre on est trois et on est à
la proximité vraiment des gens on on
peut parler avec eux on peut leur
expliquer ce qu'on joue les instruments
enfin dialoguer avec eux et puis surtout
on peut voir l'effet de la musique /
donc ces gens ils sont fragilisés en
plus par leur condition
si on parle à l'hôpital par exemple leur
condition de patients les gens qui sont
fragilisés par la souffrance et la
maladie
en plus ils sont tous en tenue d'hôpital
donc le chef d'entreprise comme
l'ouvrier ben il va pas
son avantage il est dans une situation
neutre on va dire ce qui fait que ces
gens sont un peu nu devant nous et nous
finalement aussi parce que l'on l'offre
on leur offre quelque chose d'un team
quand on joue on offre quelque chose qui
vient au plus profond de nous et
finalement et ben par cette proximité
on peut dire que l'émotion elle est
presque palpable et que c'était toujours
des expériences qui nous nourrissent et
qui nous rendent peut-être plus fort en
tout cas qui nous qui nous paraissent
importantes quand on joue par exemple
dans un service de néonatalogie ou les
bébés soient en couveuse
on joue devant des prématurés des mets
tout petits qui sont en train de lutter
pour vivre et en général dans ces
endroits il ya beaucoup de bruit il ya
le bruit des machines mais il ya surtout
les pleurs et les cris des enfants
eh bien on l'a vécu à chaque fois ça se
produit quand on commence à jouer les
pleurs s'arrêtent instantanément
il n'y a plus que le bruit des machines
et nous et ça c'est des moments forts on
alain person pression de parler un
langage universel
c'est tout petit bébé de quelques jours
qui se met à écouter de toute leurs
oreilles pourtant ils n'ont aucune clé
pour décoder le langage qu'on utilise
donc c'est bien la preuve que c'est un
langage universel qui peut toucher tout
le monde
parfois dans les prisons on voit des
détenus qui qui pleure à l'ecoute de
schubert debussy
ils sont vraiment ému on peut le voir
j'ai souvenir également d'un concert
qu'on avait fait dans un hôpital
pédiatrique lyonnais on jouait devant
les ascenseurs dans le hall et donc les
gens montaient dans les services
centraux faire attention à nous
d'ailleurs
par contre quand l'ascenseur descendait
et qui déversait les gens les familles
et les patients passent vers les
musiciens alors déjà il était étonné
parce que on n'a pas l'habitude de voir
un musicien
un des musiciens dans un rôle d'hôpital
mais ces gens là on voyait qu'ils
étaient apaisées
non seulement par la musique mais aussi
par le fait de se dire finalement cet
endroit où je laisse mon enfant malade
c'est un lieu de vie c'est un lieu où la
vie pénètre et donc ça ça donne un grand
sens à notre métier
bien sûr alors parfois on a des
expériences un peu moins positive auprès
de certains publics qui n'ont pas de pas
d'auto-censure les enfants ou les
personnes handicapées mentales sont pas
forcément soumises à un code social ou
de politesse et donc ont joué dans un
foyer de vie pour adultes handicapés
mentaux et on jouait du chostakovitch
c'était une pièce un peu ironique un peu
dissonante et ça n'a pas plu du tout à
des patients qui s'est mis à hurler mais
toutes les trois secondes mais pendant
toute la durée de la pièce c'est nul c
nul c nul
bon alors on a continué à jouer c'était
un petit peu difficile mais c'est vrai
que nous sommes on sait à quoi s'en
tenir avec ça ça remet les pendules à
l'heure on descend un peu notre tour
d'ivoire je pense que c'est très
profitable pour tout le monde voilà donc
de nombreuses associations bien sûr
interviennent dans les hôpitaux
notamment auprès des enfants bloquent
certaines d'entre elles rémunèrent leurs
artistes
donc nous on n'a pas vocation bien sûr à
évincer c'est des collègues est en fait
en proposant un service gratuit mais
simplement on pense qu' il n'y a jamais
trop de musique
il n'y a jamais trop de culture où qu'on
soit et on est content de pouvoir en
amener un peu plus
en faisant ce qu'on sait faire
finalement on veut aider les gens mais
moi par exemple si je veux parler partir
avec médecins sans frontières je vais je
vais en vérité tout le monde je sais
rien faire donc finalement je sais faire
quoi je sais faire de la musique je sais
on sait donner des concerts
donc on a décidé de faire ça pour
essayer d'avancer un peu dans l'humanité
de proposer un peu d'émotion un peu
d'humanité à ces gens et donner de notre
temps puisqu'on a la chance aussi d'être
membre de d'orchestre permanent donc on
a la possibilité de le faire et c'est ce
qu'on a choisi de faire merci pour votre
attention